it's one of the most populous nations in
the world starved of one of the world's
most precious resources the internet is
how we connect to the modern world but
today unfortunately worldwide only a
little more than a third of people have
any access to the Internet at all in
India the numbers are even more dire of
1.1 billion people only 15% are online
and so we find mark zuckerberg visiting
students in a village on the outskirts
of New Delhi the founder of Facebook
revolutionized how people communicate
now he has an even more ambitious goal
we believe that connecting everyone in
the world is one of the great challenges
of our generation and that's why we're
really happy to be able to play you know
whatever small part in that we can
Zuckerberg calls his plan to wire the
world internet org and he's been
spreading the message from India to
Indonesia we launched this effort
internet org it's our effort with a
handful of other technology companies to
bring affordable basic services to
everyone in the world from the lips of
the guy who created Facebook it sounds
eminently possible but his team admits
it's been far from easy it's challenging
because there are market dynamics in
every market that are different you go
to these villages and you ask them do
you want the internet and people are
like why would I want the Internet but
you ask me what they want Facebook oh
absolutely
Zuckerberg hand-picked emai arch' bong
and Chris Daniels to pioneer Facebook's
internet.org efforts and they've been
crisscrossing the globe ever since how
do you think having the Internet has
changed people's lives their mission to
convince mobile carriers to offer a
limited version of the internet for free
here's how it works
Facebook custom builds an internet or
website for each partner country the
site links to local weather news jobs
health resources and finally to Facebook
all at zero cost to the user the idea is
that users get hooked on the internet
and buy a data plan when the free access
ends creating new customers for the
carriers and new users for Facebook why
call it org is this a non-profit is this
charity you know if we were primarily
focused on profits the most reasonable
thing for us to do
would be to really just focus on the
first billion people who are using our
products
you said connectivity is a human right
you want to do good things if that's the
case why not give access to the complete
Internet why just a few specific apps
the model that we consider this to be
most similar to is 911 so even if you
haven't paid for a phone plan you can
always dial nine-one-one Tim Wu is a
professor at Columbia University and a
public policy advocate why would a
company want to give away a product for
free they think they can build the
world's most powerful device for
accessing hearts and minds of the human
race and sell that to somebody else and
Facebook is just one of many Internet
giant's in an epic global battle to win
heart and mind share 7 billion people on
the planet whoever gets the biggest
share of that might be expected to
dominate the future of media period one
not to be dominated Google has Project
loon a fleet of high-altitude balloons
already circling the planet meaning the
internet down to earth a new company
called one web in space X's Elon Musk
both recently announced plans to launch
low orbit satellites that will carry the
internet everywhere and Facebook has
some moon shots of its own led by a mad
scientist of sorts Yael Maguire laser
communications is sort of a new frontier
where you can get much much higher data
rates than it's typically done in a
Southern California lab still being
built Maguire and a team of former NASA
engineers are developing lasers that
will send the Internet to earth in a
beam of light for all of the developed
markets that were looking at trying to
improve access we want to use laser
communications everywhere Maguire plans
to put lasers inside unmanned aerial
vehicles solar-powered planes that
continuously circle above the earth
the world record for solar powered
flight is around two weeks we need to
figure out how to make these planes last
four months two years at a time
the advantage of planes drones and
satellites they don't rely on cell
towers or any earth-based
infrastructure McGuire says connectivity
from the sky is still three to five
years out for internet.org but expects
to test the first Facebook drum later
this year once you get people connected
once you have the power to reach them
how do you use that power for us it's
really all about enabling people
whatever that means in India and
Indonesia Zuckerberg plan seems to be
working
carriers in both countries recently
announced partnerships with Internet org
giving millions of new people access to
the Internet and to Facebook how will
you judge that this has been a success
if we can make it so that free basic
services are available in 100 or more
countries then that is going to be a
huge win for all of these people who
will now have access to new information
on jobs and health care and education
you said you hoped for more than a
billion people by 2020 do you think you
can get there we'll see whether it's the
Internet or the Internet according to
Facebook it's the kind of grand plan you
can only expect from Mark Zuckerberg the
real question is can he changed the
world not once but twice
Emily Chang Bloomberg Menlo Park
California